So let's talk about something called scatter plots.
And I'm going to use the car example.
When we drove our car we had days when the terrain was completely flat,
let us drive very fast.
Sometimes we encountered a little bit of bumpiness or a lot of bumpiness.
Which kind of forces us to slow down.
So one way in which our terrain was able to vary, was at the level of bumpiness.
Which could go from smooth, to really bad.
Second dimension, which our terrain varied had to do with slope.
Could be flat.
Or, they were different levels of steepness.
I'm obviously slightly exaggerating here.
So it goes from flat to very steep.
And, again, the steeper it is the slower we wish to drive.
And, those things could co-occur,
as shown in these scater graphs on the right side.
So what I want to do with you is just map these training examples over here,
of say a flat, smooth vote, into our diagram over here.
And I give you nine possible points that correspond to
all the combinations of the three bumpiness levels we encountered.
And the three slope levels.
And when I ask you to take a car set away from, like, this one and then define
the correct of the nine items that best represents the situation over here